welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Spider-Man across the spider
versus biggest Cameo Donald Glover is an
alternate universe Aaron Davis Prowler
is one we're all still reeling from
because it blew up in the possibilities
of the spider-verse and left us with so
many questions of what Universe this
Prowler came from how was he captured
and what this all really means
I need a minute to think about this
we're gonna get through these bats
because as he told us it's rude to stare
support us with a Miles Morales
Multiverse dive shirt at nerd riot.shop
and subscribe to the Deep dive Channel
and check out our Spielberg summer
content and subscribe to our new channel
the break room Donald Glover's Cameo and
Spider-Man across the spider-verse comes
up in the spider Society HQ in Nueva
York when Lila takes miles on a tour of
the multiversal anomalies being prepped
for the go home machine Donald Glover
appears in live action alongside the
animated Miles Morales wearing an
original Prowler costume with the chunky
spiky gloves and the prowler logo in
purple on the chest he mutters hey and
then it's rude to stare Hobie Brown says
caught that one myself it probably says
I slipped and then Gwen snaps at Hobie
you I did all the work so like Adriano
tumino vulture in the opening sequence
Donald Glover Prowler was another recent
anomaly who glitched into the wrong
universe and he was captured by both
Hobie Brown and When Stacy working
together now we've talked about the
deeper significance of Donald Glover's
Cameo here just to recap Glover played
Aaron Davis in the MCU in Spider-Man
homecoming a not yet suited up Prowler
but but the prowler was listed among his
criminal aliases when Peter Parker
looked him up in the mask's heads-up
display earlier in the movie when Peter
confronted him he referenced having a
nephew I don't want those weapons in
this neighborhood I got a nephew who
live here and in the deleted scene we
learned that nephew's name was Miles
yeah sorry miles I'm not going to make
it Donald Glover had previously cameo in
the 2018 into the spider-verse on the TV
in Uncle Aaron's apartment from the
episode of NBC's Community when Troy
wore Spider-Man pajamas and that was
reference to a fan campaign in 2012 to
get Sony to cast Donald Glover as their
next Spider-Man but Sony went with
Andrew Garfield of course yet that Peter
Parker had a poster of Donald Glover or
asteroid on his bedroom wall in 2012's
The Amazing Spider-Man and in 2014
Donald Glover voicemails Morales in the
Disney XD Series Ultimate Spider-Man so
really he's just been associated with
the character for a long time and his
inclusion here is meant to honor that
history but Lauren Miller recently told
Rolling Stone that it was quote a
personal reach out to Donald that he
would quote commit to nothing by doing
it and they said that Glover agreed
saying that he wanted to surprise his
kids they said that Tracy geeky field
the costume designer from the show that
after already built a Prowler suit in a
matter of weeks and when they were asked
about the decision to include Glover in
live action as opposed to animating him
in a different style Miller said that
they never considered doing an animated
version of Donald Glover that wasn't
true to the universe that his character
came from so it sounds like Lord and
Miller had something specific in mind
when it comes to what universe exactly
this version of the prowler comes from
so is this the same Aaron Davis from the
MCU in Spider-Man homecoming well it's
hard to say like when you watch Donald
Glover's performance in Spider-Man
homecoming he's definitely going for a
different vibe than the character he
plays in across the spider-verse like
compare Glovers it's rude to stare to
Glover's performance as Aaron Davis in
homecoming I heard you got a bridge I
know what A girl sound like you ain't
never done this before huh I like bread
now that's not to say Aaron Davis and
homecoming couldn't have changed in the
past few years homecoming was before the
blip since Peter Parker was dusted
during that flip and New York turned
into a rough place for a few years it's
possible someone like Aaron Davis could
have gone down a darker path and become
a fully suited up super villain now to
be clear about this across the
spider-verse suggests that all recent
anomalies were for the result of Earth
1610 kingpins outcomex and the spider
from Earth 42 biting miles so it would
have been that not any infinity stone
event in the MCU or events from Loki or
the ruins of Costco and Spider-Man no
way home misfiring none of that but
really the events of the 2018 into the
spider-verse film that caused Aaron
Davis Prowler played by Donald Glover to
end up in the wrong universe and
wherever he ended up Hobie Brown and
Gwen Stacy teamed up to catch him after
in prowler's words he slipped now again
Lord and Miller said they told Glover
that this Cameo wouldn't commit him to
anything and they've also gone into
further detail about the boundaries
between their animated Multiverse and
the MCU and of their live-action
universes of course there was the Miguel
O'Hara reference to doctor strange and
the little nerd in Earth 1999 and
glimpses of Andrew Garfield and Toby
McGuire Peter Parkers and the universe
of Tom Hardy Venom which are by
association connected to the MCU summer
is the perfect time to travel and if you
want to get the most out of your trip
you're going to want to use Babel to
learn a language before you go anywhere
Babel is one of the top language
learning apps in the world it is
scientifically proven to help you start
speaking new language in just three
weeks Babel's lessons are designed by
real language teachers your subscription
even comes with two free live classes
babble's method is simple it teaches you
real world conversations so you're
prepared to have practical conversations
about travel business relationships and
more even if you just want to let people
know estoya espanol por favor
the Babel subscription might be what you
need if you're really in love with the
language get a lifetime subscription if
you're just flirting with a poor and
tongue there are monthly options
available as well no matter what you
need Babel has you covered click the
link in the description below to get 60
off your battle subscription today in
that Rolling Stone interview Lauren had
this interesting quote saying we are
always trying to assert that things that
you think are sealed off from one
another are not the movie's point of
view is that the boundaries you've been
told are there aren't really there and
they said yes that included the glimpses
of Andrew Garfield and Toby McGuire and
that Kevin feige gave his Blessing for
things like the reference to Doctor
Strange in the Tom Holland Spider-Man
but the fact that Lord Miller said that
Glovers cameo wouldn't commit him to
anything and that Glover definitely
seems to be doing a different take on
the character whereas remember Andrew
Garfield told me why are those guys who
are doing their best to embody their
past takes on Peter Parker I don't think
this is the Aaron Davis from the MCU
like implying that he was the MCU Aaron
Davis would commit Donald Glover to
higher expectations of a real MCU future
also in the events of Spider-Man
homecoming that particular take on the
vulture and the Shocker and the other
people in that world didn't really have
the comic accurate suits whereas in
across the spider versus suit that
Donald Glover is wearing is far more
comic accurate or at least a live-action
version of what the animated Aaron Davis
wears however a specific live-action
Aaron Davis may come from a live-action
Universe centered around a live-action
Miles Morales remember Amy Pascal
confirmed a live-action Miles Morales
movie is in the works and I think a
cross spiderverse might have actually
shown it to us here what do you want I'm
robbing you because I'm a bad guy in
this movie they label this earth688 this
is Mrs chins Bodega from the Venom films
and while our first assumption was that
this was the universe of Venom and
Carnage this pack of gum makes me
rethink it you see the spot picking it
up and it reads Brock's venomint why
would investigative reporter Tom Hardy
Eddie Brock have a brand of gum named
after his symbiote now I get it for
practical reasons once breath probably
stinks after eating people so you know
it's definitely handy to have around but
I think this not the MCU is the reality
Aaron Davis Prowler came from and it's
the one where Sony plans to introduce
their live-action Miles Morales it could
be why Miss Chen would be so unfazed by
seeing an animated spot Papa said to her
Universe because this universe already
would have been affected by live action
to animation and vice versa multiversal
glitches I think Sony's gonna want some
separate live-action Universe to
introduce their Miles Morales in because
they're going to want distinct control
over this character and only share him
with the MCU through future mutually
beneficial multiversal crossover events
like Avengers Secret Wars so the
question now is who should play live
action Miles Morales shamik Moore wants
it to be him but I get the feedback that
Miles Morales Puerto Rican Heritage is a
big part of his character and we can't
really ignore that so I'm gonna hear
from you comment down below with your
thoughts remember to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive And subscribe
to the break room grab a Multiverse dive
shirt at nerd riot.shop follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eat a boss
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign